I'm so we're going to be microchipping
dogs for free and march on the 19th and
20th which is a saturday and sunday
between 11am into p.m. and we just want
to offer the public a free day where
they can come and get their dog
microchipped and it helps if we pick the
dog up day we can scan them to see where
they live if they don't have any tags on
or if the dog is stolen or anything like
that we can scan them and see what
brings up all their details people can't
afford to go to the vet clinic to get
their dog microchipped and with the new
while the dog lawyer you have to have
your dog microchipped now since 2006
we're going to offer registration for
fifty dollars for anybody with a new dog
so that sort of a one-off fee we don't
normally offer that it's for anyone who
has a new dog that has never been
registered before we're going to offer
that otherwise it's normally 125 dollars
it's going to be for a wide range of
paper works for everyone so everyone can
come down and register their dog and get
their dog microchipped I think being in
Southland that rains quite a bit so
we're going to bring the caravan down so
we've got a better shelter when we do
microchip them and so there's going to
be three in more control officers and we
will come down here between 11 and two
and microchip them a few swap bodies got
any questions or anything we can help
answer them or behavioral issues or
barking or wandering we can try and help
out with some advice for them I think
it's pretty important that people
register the dogs save like if their dog
did get out and was wondering we can
find where the dog liver site goes home
rather than going to the pound and that
costing more money so if anybody wants
any more information they can go to ICC
govt TMZ and it has everything up there
and what they need to know
you